und so backt auch ihr die perfekte Tarte
in nur wenigen Schritten verwende für
den Teig auf jeden Fall kalte Butter
verknete sie dann mit dem Zucker Salz
und Eigelb in einer Rührschüssel
Vanilleextrakt und Zitronenschale gerne
noch mit dazugeben und dann das Mehl
einrühren die Zutaten sollten jetzt
wirklich nur kurz verknetet werden damit
der Teig schön kalt bleibt jetzt den
Teig zu einer Kugelformen flachdrücken
und abdecken und für mindestens eine
Stunde kühlen der Teig wird jetzt vor
dem Ausrollen noch einmal kräftig
durchgeknetet und dann am besten mit
Hilfe eines ausrollstabs und 5 mm
Abstandsring richtig perfekt ausgerollt
zum Ausrollen hier jetzt wirklich nur
ganz wenig Mehl verwenden damit der Teig
nicht austrocknet verwendet am besten
eine Tarteform mit hebelboden so backt
der Teig nämlich perfekt durch und ihr
könnt später die Tat ganz einfach
herauslösen den Teig lege ich jetzt
vorsichtig rein drück ihn schön in die
Ecken hinein und den Rest des Tages
könnt ihr oben mit der Winkelpalette
Schöneck streichen und mein Geheimtipp
am besten vor dem Backen noch mal für 10
Minuten einfrieren dann behält der Teig
nämlich beim Backen auf seine Form